this other dude I screwed up against I
know I squared up do you remember the
story when we were doing reality bites
back when we were doing the so you think
you can die of episode okay I drove us
all down there do you remember that yes
I drove all down and the practice day
the practice day that we had and for
those who don't know it was a show on
Comedy Central that was it was a great
great show to be on it was a lot of fun
the big payday it was cool not it wasn't
a big payday a big payday for baby for
you though yeah big payday for they
[ __ ] up it was it was I'm gonna say
this number is the wrong number but it
was in my memory it was like $8,000 in
episode yeah and but and so all of us
looked at it more like it's a 10 that
order episode officer like we got an 80
[ __ ] grand and the winner gets like
quarter of a million dollars whatever or
a hundred thousand dollars yeah and then
we got through the first day and
realized if you get kicked off you don't
get a grant yeah and it came became
couple it's the only episodes you were
on you got eight grand for each episode
you were on i remembers episode somebody
got kicked off me you I've told this
story every toss all right grant a week
ago really in Baltimore yeah he I saw
the picture he came out my show yeah
really cool it's great to see him oh
hung out with him and Donnell I didn't
episode of something's burning with them
and we end up smoking weed just [ __ ]
that's awesome um the first day the very
first day were sitting at that mansion
outside of Encino
it's me you read grant Donnell Rawlings
on the step mm-hmm if I'm not mistaken
and Kyle seats came up and he had the
Hat that said
week one he had a hat made out for every
week week 1 week 2 week 3 week 4 and
he's with Chris Fairbanks yeah and he
goes and Donnell goes yes son that's
right you are the week one and we all
start laughing Kyle goes I I think I
think it's spelled everything goes no no
son you should have had that just says
week and then Kyle goes I don't know I
think it's I think it's spelled
differently and he goes not in my
neighborhood
and then Kyle walks away I go Chris and
he just goes he goes I think I'm next
and just walked away that was so funny
me you me you read grant got naked in
the bathtub with luenell oh yeah you
remember that yeah yeah like I got
full-blown naked
he always did I got full of naked I got
full-blown naked dick against the glass
and the president Lauren creo is in at
that shooting president Comedy Central
and it's what happened is me you and me
you and reg get a passage to the next
round and they go your reward is you get
to shower and bathe with Linnell and so
we're like oh [ __ ] it we don't care yeah
and so we go in she's small I think they
get a small body I think they give us
cocktails we were drinking before that
yeah yeah and she got us in there yep Oh
picture luenell I ran in her by the way
I thought she hated me I ran into her in
Montreal mmm just got [ __ ] wasted
with her and had a blast oh yeah she's
fun everybody loves her and we got in
the bathtub and luenell goes I'm taking
off my drawers or whatever oh yeah pulls
her bathing suit bottoms off it oh no
he's him out and I was like [ __ ] I'm
in so I take mine off Fred takes his off
you take yours off and then she stands
up and she still got him on she had two
pair naked praise God man those are the
good old days
think about how long ago that was it
sure was fun one year was that go back
to that information if you don't mind 8
1994 derived from 1994 uh 2008 Wow I got
a special right after that 2008 2008 Wow
someone wait will keep up who got voted
off when someone sent me as if drive
that has all the episodes to I have it
on I drive someplace if either of you
want that I would love to see that
there's a great I was when like look
people I think a lot of people in this
business take ownership of when they
find when they feel like they discover
someone they know like like there's a
lot of agents that do that I would say
without a doubt without a doubt me and
Amy Schumer became the biggest deal of
home fans in the [ __ ] world like I
remember me and Amy looking at each
other and being like you were so funny
and it was effortless you weren't even
trying to be funny you were just so
[ __ ] funny I swear to God I pay
$100,000 to have all the footage raw
footage got my own show of the outtakes
there were times where you'd leave
Michael Ian Black just like huh and we
were not
laughing he was like a white supremacist
I felt like it laid rest
I remember we go we were all talking and
he we go so what do you hope the show
get to you what I hope to show it to you
all of you get a special I love you get
30 minutes I love to get on premium
planning me like what about you Michael
and he goes a new basement and we're
like what he goes that's the only reason
I'm doing this show I need a new
basement and we were like cool yeah he
always had this white supremacist about
he just looked to white
I broke white down a little you know
really bring him a picture of him he
does he does look he does have a vibe of
like like like the bad guy in a Harry
Potter movie Michael Ian Black
yeah he did he yeah he texted me last
night he was so funny yeah I'll see if I
can see the text he literally just
texted me last hour my [ __ ] phone oh
there he is right there he definitely
looks like he would be giving a speech
about hey you know no prob sorry I have
here sorry all the white women vote
looks like he doesn't blink his eyes at
night water okay what's that one Michael
Ian Black defends louis c.k oh that's
kind of cool
well my be is a cool dude man I love him
dude he's one of a kind for he really is
man and it was by the way he's always
been sweet like ever since we met him
he's a ballbuster kind of like that's
his angle of comedy but he's always been
very sweet guy I remember we connected
because both our wives are older than us
and I Yi Li
yeah yeah and his wife's older than him
and my wife's I mean me MIB are the same
age and and did you ever see his TV show
the state yeah I want to dip my balls
how great was that it was the greatest
[ __ ] show I feel like I feel like
what I'm hearing is you don't like the
tacos no I love the talked to us in fact
the best tacos I've ever had dude that
that show was so [ __ ] great did you
ever see a thousand pounds of pudding uh
yeah
oh dude I could watch that show that was
one of my favorite shows that was the
first time I really got comedy Wow
put type in no protective putting the
state yeah yeah yeah yeah there you go
that was I think it was $240 worth I'm
sorry I said a thousand every time I
tell story $240 with the pudding mr.
Boucher come on in here by the way they
were like to us what it dollars combined
we had the 240 we $100 with the puddin
[Music]
with 240 dollars with the pudding now I
know what you're thinking
burying the bone where did you get 240
dollars
[Music]
don't worry your pretty little head
about a building in your concerns now if
you excuse me I got a whisper some sweet
nuts just put I'll just be over here
minding my own
they were chill this is like the
silliest [ __ ] yes we were in college we
were college smoking we used to go to
parties ago yeah we did like yours no I
don't want it I can again does anyone
have some orange juice I've got some
orange juice
I want to dip my balls in it that guy
came reading good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one